et ce nouveau chiffre maintenant qui
fait froid dans le dos d'après l'unicef
plus de la moitié des enfants ukrainiens
ont dû quitter leur maison depuis le
début de la guerre il y à un mois quatre
millions trois cent mille enfants
déplacés à cause de cette guerre parmi
eux près de 2 millions ont été ont
quitté l'ukraine les autres ont été
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays
et je suis maintenant avec tarek aillent
bon jour tarek vous les avez rencontré
on s'est déplacé parce que vous venez de
revenir de d'ukraine et de pologne où
vous avez passé plusieurs jours qu'est
ce qui vous a le plus marqué sur le
terrain nous avons passé près de plus de
deux semaines en ukraine où on était
vraiment au plus près de ces populations
qui file au conflit notre couverture a
commencé après match précisément donc
shemesh la dernière ville polonaise au
niveau de cette frontière entre la
pologne et l'ukraine et c'est là où
arrivent des milliers de ces est réfugié
qui filent conflit que ce soit des
familles des enfants des personnes âgées
et mèche qui est aujourd'hui considéré
comme étant de la porte d'entrée sur le
territoire européen
donc ces scènes elle et elle est un peu
les mêmes que ce soit du côté polonais
ou du côté ukrainien avec des gens qui
sont complètement éprouvé des milliers
qui arrive à bord de ses trains de bus
de voiture ou même certains ont effectué
cette traversée de la frontière à pied
c'est même scène on les a vus donc qu'il
s'agit d'ukrainiens ou même de
ressortissants étrangers dont certains
ont fui la guerre elle complique dans
leurs pays respectifs et qui ont voulu
faire une refaire une nouvelle vie en
ukraine tourner la page et se sont
retrouvés à très près par ce conflit ces
mêmes scènes on les a vus également à
lviv lviv donc dernière ville à l'ouest
de l'ukraine
vive point d'arrivée de dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés de déplacer de
façon quotidienne
ce sont ces mêmes témoignages cette même
fatigue ces gens éprouvés par cette
tragédie des gens qui ont effectué un
périple de 20 heures de 25 heures dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
des fois debout sans boire ni manger en
emportant tatus quelques affaires
personnelles
et quand on parle justement de cette
crise qui s'écrit actuellement en
ukraine comme étant la pire depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale en termes de fg
de déplacés on la voit véritablement à
lviv on l'a vu de nos propres yeux c'est
que qui se forme devant la gare centrale
de lviv
sous la pluie sous la neige que ce soit
à 19h à 7h du matin des gens qui
essayent coûte que coûte de quitter cet
enfer ukrainien alors certains sont
arrivés à temps pour fuir justement ces
bombardements et d'autres se sont vus
retrouvé coincé sous occupation russe on
a rencontré une famille justement qu'il
vient de de la vie de reus thomel dans
la région de kiev on a rencontré cette
mère de famille qui venait juste
d'arriver en en lieu sûr et je vous
propose d'écouter son témoignage
on avait même pas de pain pendant deux
semaines il n'y avait plus rien dans les
magasins les troupes russes ont tout
volé ils ont cassé les serrures défoncé
les portes volets toutes les
marchandises ils n'ont rien laissé
hills à l'aide d'une maison à l'autre
détruisant les serrures et les portes
criant aux gens aller en russie
l'ukraine c'est le mal la russie c'est
le bien quand nous sommes partis nous
n'avions plus d'essence ils ont coupé le
gaz en disant que c'était du gaz russe
il me disait que je devais remercier
dieu puisque j'étais toujours en vie les
d'akwa ibom aux chevauchées
voilà pour ce témoignage est évidemment
qui fait froid dans le dos tarek partout
vous avez été il ya eu des bombardements
russes vous êtes allé à lviv à vinnytsia
âge et au maire ces villes ont été quand
même moins bombardé que d'autres comme
marioupol par exemple qui est une ville
martyre depuis le début de cette guerre
est ce que ces villes qui sont moins
bombardé se prépare au pire comment se
prépare t elle tout à fait on peut dire
de manière générale qu'aucune ville en
ukraine aujourd'hui est à l'abri de
bombardements russes même si certaines
font partie de cibles prioritaires plus
prioritaires disons par rapport à
l'armée russe partout on a été les
sirènes d'alarmé autant tissés à
longueur de journée toutes ces villes
qu'on a visités comme vous l'avez dit
que ce soit le vivent à l'ouest
vinnytsia au centre ouest où même et
agito mer à 150 kilomètres de kiev ces
villes ont été bombardées avant notre
arrivée pendant et après notre départ
donc évidemment ces villes se prépare à
des lendemains beaucoup plus difficile à
lviv par exemple tout le patrimoine
culturel a été protégée de vivre qui est
considéré comme étant la capitale
culturelle d'ukraine riche d'un
patrimoine architectural artistique
les oeuvres d'art ont été
abrités en fait déplacer dans des lieux
sur des statues ont été couvertes de
bâches certains bâtiments ont été
couverts de deux planches de bois pour
les
sauvegarder pour les sauver en cas de de
frappe russe nous avons vu également
aussi des distilleries de bière qui ont
été transformés en ateliers de
fabrication de cocktails molotov ou
d'obstacles antichars et les maires dans
ce dispositif joue un rôle considérable
nous avons rencontré le maire de g
thomas un ancien militaire qui a son
idée et son propre avis sur les
événements en quoi
leur matériel et vieux leurs munitions
sont volés on voit qu'il envoie des
jeunes de 18 à 20 ans aux combats ce
n'est pas une armée de personnes qui se
sont engagés volontairement c'est une
armée de conscrits qui ont été jetés
dans le hachoir à viande
ils sont visés des crèches des écoles et
des zones résidentielles alors que je
pense il essayait de viser des cibles
militaires
et parmi ces sites dont parle le maire
donc on a pu visiter des écoles qui ont
été bombardés l'hôpital est également
certains quartiers résidentiels qui ont
fait beaucoup de morts merci beaucoup
pour ce retour de terrain tard à kayes
merci à vous de votre fidélité